sie befürchten nämlich sozusagen kann
man sagen wenn Blackout der Wirtschaft
sie befürchten ein Umbau unseres
Wirtschaftssystem und wir müssen über
Robert Habeck reden denn der sagen sie
ganz klar macht die Sache derzeit nicht
unbedingt besser nein Kamera ihre Zeit
danke schön ja also Frau Merkel hat es
ja schon in Davos gesagt dass wir eine
große Transformation vor uns haben
gigantischen Ausmaßes diese große
Transformation ist eigentlich die
Überführung der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
in eine
klimaneutrale Wirtschaft die genau
betrachtet letztendlich eine
Planwirtschaft ist eine ökologistische
Planwirtschaft oder Kommando Wirtschaft
dahinter steht natürlich die Vorstellung
der großen Transformation von einem
Österreich ungarischen
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler polani der
sagte ja das ganz schlimme was passiert
ist ist dass die Wirtschaft die Macht
übernommen hat und die Politik sekundär
ist und das müssen wir jetzt umdrehen
und das ist die Politik von Robert
Habeck nämlich dass man sagt die Politik
muss wieder die Macht übernehmen und der
Grundsatz laut die Politik gibt die
Richtungen vor und wenn die Politik die
Richtungen vorgegeben hat dann soll die
Wirtschaft folgen dann darf dürfen die
Märkte frei sein aber man will die
Richtung Vorgehen man will neue
Wertschöpfungsketten schaffen man will
neue Märkte schaffen man will über
Subventionen und über Interventionen die
Wirtschaft in anderen bestimmten Punkt
bringen und der Umbau bedeutet dass wir
eigentlich die industrialisieren
anders übertreibt er ist Ihnen das zu
dieser gezeichnet
also nein
tatsächlich
verteidigt die Meinung dass Robert habe
ich würde es anders ein bisschen anders
formulieren aber im Kern stimme ich
Ihnen zu
Robert habe ist natürlich voller
Ideologie und natürlich Glaubenssätze
grüne Art wir versucht umzusetzen
Politik das wird bei Grünen immer etwas
unterschätzt wie stark sie natürlich
ihre Politik klingt jetzt etwas banal
aber wie stark Sie ihre Politik
tatsächlich schnell in Gesetz umsetzen
wollen und auch können weil sie in der
Regel dieses Fach sehr sehr gut
beherrscht die SPD macht das ja alles
mit die SPD stellt den Kanzlerin stellt
den Kanzler wie sehen auch ein
zunehmenden schwenkenden Energie Fragen
ein bisschen unbemerkt zum Kanzler das
Jahr zu Atomkraft wenn auch nur
für kurze Zeit der erste Schritt dann
das Heranziehen der Kompetenz bei der
Gewinnung von Energie beim ersten Mal
waren sie beide noch mal nach dieser
etwas glücklosen Reise von Robert Habeck
in die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
und nach kataro in nichts bei
rausgekommen ist da kannst du ihn noch
mal mitgenommen machen Kanada da haben
sie gemeinsam gesprochen und die nächste
Reise nach Saudi-Arabien und ihnen die
VRR hat Olaf Scholz dann alleine gemacht
weil eben natürlich merkt dass das
passiert was sie sagen es gibt diese man
nennt sie intern die all electric
Fraktion also sie wollen alles
elektrisch machen im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit großer
connections
Energiewende die auch dieses Ziel hat
also insofern hier sind welche unterwegs
unsere Wirtschaft natürlich in diese
Richtung umbauen wollen ich glaube oder
Stolz hat mittlerweile gesehen so geht
das nicht und das verhindert bringt sich
zumindest immer mehr ein in dieses ganze
Thema und ich glaube er sieht dass alle
Elektrik nicht reicht
ist das nicht neuer Zopf für die
Koalition also die Grüne sind jetzt
nicht alleine es gibt ja noch zwei
andere Parteien wie mächtig ist Robert
Habeck da überhaupt um dieses Szenario
so umzusetzen ich bin gar nicht sicher
ob jetzt Robert Habeck als Person der
steht jetzt auf dieser Position aber in
Robert Habeck ist ja auch nicht alleine
das Wirtschaftsministerium und der ist
auch nicht alleine die Grünen was ich
aber zeigt ist schon in der Tat
sozusagen diese Ideologie die
unglaublich stark ist und von der man
auch überhaupt nicht abweichen will weil
es ja auch die Identität dieser Partei
ausmacht ja also in mitten in einer
Energiekrise die letzten Kernkraftwerke
abzuschalten ist ja nahezu Wahnsinn ja
das ganze Ausland irgendwie schaut auf
Deutschland das sind die eigentlich
wahnsinnig ja und das zeigt aber es ist
Atomenergie ist sozusagen ja die die die
die
Gründungsmythos der Grünen sind
immer angekündigt und da bleiben sie
sich quasi toll sie bleiben sich treu
und der Widerstand eben aus der
Koalition ist in der sie sind ist
offensichtlich so gering das beantwortet
Ihre Frage dass die Grünen hier
weitermachen können also ich sagen weil
es ist ja schön zu hören wenn Olaf
Scholz langsam merkt das läuft so nicht
und ein bisschen dagegen arbeitet aber
mit Verlaub hier braucht eine Notbremse
ja das ist nicht so wir brauchen hier
nicht ein notching sondern wir brauchen
eine Notbremse wir brauchen eine eine
Grund neu aufgestellte Energiepolitik ja
wir kaufen Gas von weißgott her haben
aber Gas für die nächsten 100 Jahre im
eigenen Land auch noch sagen aber nicht
fördern wollen das heißt wir sind bereit
Tracking Gas zu kaufen aber nicht
Tracking Gas zu fördern herstellen
würden als die Amerikaner das tun
Technologien haben
Atomstrom zu produzieren kaufen ihn aber
aus schlechteren Atomkraftwerken aus dem
Ausland ja und all diese Unlogik trifft
quasi bei den Grünen zusammen und
niemand hält sie auf und mir ist es ein
Rätsel warum hier eigentlich nicht genug
vernünftige Kräfte auch im Bundestag und
insgesamt auch in der Koalition sitzen
wahrscheinlich brauchen wir erst so ein
Blackout oder irgend so etwas damit auch
innerhalb der Bevölkerung endlich klar
ist dass das ein Weg ist den wir einfach
nicht gehen können das glauben Sie Herr
mai warum gibt es da nicht mehr
Widerstand das funktioniert es ist ja
nicht es ist ja nicht Robert habe ich
allein und es ist nicht nur Ideologie
also man darf eins nicht vergessen dass
die gesamte klimaindustrie ich nenne sie
jetzt mal so sie nennens allelektrik
aber diese diesen ganzen dieser ganze
Komplex ist ein Milliarden wenn nicht
ein billionengeschäft da wird investiert
sehen sie nur in der in der EU den
großen Fonds next generation Europe das
sind 750 Milliarden Euro die zum großen
Teil geliehen werden die laufen über
Kredit wer verdient an den Krediten da
gibt es da gibt es im Grunde ganz große
Interessen Gleichheiten zwischen einer
Hochfinanz und den Umbau Vorstellungen
der Grünen ich weiß das klingt nach
Verschwörungstheorie aber man kann sich
so schwer vorstellen nur historische
Konstellationen sind manchmal schwer
vorstellbar und ich sag das mal in einem
Bild es ist so und deswegen macht es es
so schwer dass Prinz John der Sheriff
von Nottingham und Robin Hood gemeinsame
Sache machen das ist die Situation die
wir haben es war ihr Beispiel aber
bezirka Friedrich Merz und Robert Habeck
weil nämlich beide eine connection
Blackrock haben richtig und Blackrock
ist ja nur einer aber wenn es der muss
mal erklärt das Blackrock ist der größte
Player in dem ganzen also
ähm es gibt eine Personalie die das
schön beschreibt und zwar die
Grundsatzabteilung im
Wirtschaftsministerium das ist
eigentlich der der die nervenzentrale
das sind die die Strategien entwickeln
wird jetzt geleitet von Elgar Bartsch
ELGA Bartsch war vorher beim morgen
Stanley an Investmentbank dann war sie
beim Think Tank von Blackrock und kommt
jetzt
sozusagen dorthin und ich will davor gar
nichts unterstellen aber das ist die
Denkschule aus der sie kommt und da
sehen sie die Verbindung zwischen
klimaindustrie klimaideologie und
Finanzierung und ich glaube auch dass
und das darauf spielen sie gerade
aneinander ich glaube auch dass
ja das Friedrich Merz auch so schwer in
die in die Hufen kommt in die so schwer
Opposition machen kann weil er
auch dieser klimaindustrie verpflichtet
ist er kommt von Blackrock das ist eine
eine ähnliche Denkschule das heißt was
ich mir wünschen würde wäre wieder mal
eine anständige sozialdemokratische
Politik was ich mir wünschen wäre würde
wäre eine anständige christdemokratische
Politik
demokratischen Kanzler ja aber ja aber
naja also sie haben mir vorhin
gesprochen über das große Gesamtbild und
da gehört ja noch eine Sache dazu die
rot grüne Bundesregierung hat ja die
Atom tatsächlich eine Aussicht aus der
Atomkraft beschlossen allerdings bis zum
Jahr 2030 ähm wir hätten jetzt also noch
acht Jahre laufen Atomkraftwerke nach
der Regelung es war ein bisschen Angela
Merkel die zunächst erstmal in der
schwarz-gelben Koalition mit der FDP die
Laufzeiten verlängert hat dann kam
Fukushima und eine drohende nilanlage
bei den Landtagswahlen in
Baden-Württemberg ja oder das reinen
wahltaktischen Bewegungen um das
Stammland Baden-Württemberg nicht zu
verlieren hat sie dann den Ausstieg
überhastet aus der Atomkraft dann eben
durchgesetzt Baden-Württemberg ging
trotzdem an die Grünen hat nichts
genutzt und den Salat haben wir jetzt
und diese Salat heißt Energiewende ja
und kann mich ja dafür sein aber dann
bitte geordnet und nicht alles
gleichzeitig nicht ausgegangen von
Anfang an verloren weil wenn die wenn
man sagt wir machen einen Atomausstieg
dann hätten wir anständigerweise niemals
auch nur irgendwie eine Kilowattstunde
irgendwo kaufen dürfen ja also dann kann
man es ja nicht sein also entweder wir
steigen aus der Atomkraft auf dann kann
man aber auch nicht aus Tschechien aus
Frankreich oder sonst wo Atomstrom
kaufen Ende und dann hätten ich sage
hätte man das also sozusagen ehrlich
gemacht wäre ja sofort aufgefallen dass
das überhaupt nicht geht ja sondern man
hat den man hat den Bürgern eine
Energiewende verkauft und einen
Atomausstieg der tatsächlich ja nie
stattgefunden hat sondern wir haben
sozusagen nur nur eingestellt ihn selber
zu produzieren wir haben aber nie gesagt
dass wir ihn nicht kaufen das war schon
die Idee mit 20 30 so so lange das
auszufeden bis man dann eben die anderen
Kapazitäten aufgebaut hat und Druck
später
die Rolle von dem der Druck von der
Straße von den klimakern ist das
irgendein Druck der auf die Politik wird
in dieses Thema jetzt noch größer macht
noch aktueller macht und dann den
Widerspruch du hast ihn als Taten
Widerspruch angedeutet noch schwieriger
macht diese Frage ist für Youtube
Bewegung wenn wir bei der Anfang der hat
natürlich ein riesen im Pack gehabt ein
riesigen Einfluss gehabt auf Politik
weil jeder war mittlerweile
Klimaschützer und keiner konnte sich
diesem Thema wiedersetzen auf keine Wahl
vielleicht zwei drei Parteien noch aber
wieder keine Partei der Mitte sage ich
jetzt mal konnte sich dem widersetzen
und deswegen sind wir alle ein bisschen
davon natürlich in diese Richtung
getrieben worden aber es hätte auch den
mutbedürft zu sagen bei Dinge gehen halt
nicht wir können nicht alle gleichzeitig
abstellen alle Dinge die uns Energie
bringen nur dann um das dazu zu kaufen
von den Weltmärkten was wir selber nicht
mehr produzieren wollen wie viel mehr
Geld das ist natürlich eine glaubhafte
Polizei vor allen Dingen hätte man es
andersrum machen sollen man hätte erst
sagen müssen wo wie kann ich die Lücke
denn schließen und damit Verträge
schließen und dann erst abschalten aber
man macht ja genau andersrum man
schaltet einfach ab oder man macht jetzt
einen gasembargo gegen Russland und
wundert sich dann das 55% des Erdgases
fehlen und dann überlegt man Obst was
mache ich denn jetzt und dann rennt man
rum und macht überall den Diener um
super teures Event zu kaufen Situation
jetzt heute keine einfache Situation
kein einfacher Winter in den wieder